my student payments are sitting right
now at about $400 is what they're
expecting each month so I mean that's my
food budget right there the pandemic
freeze on student loan payments allow
Josie to open up her own Salon in
Portland Oregon but with $4,000 in
outstanding debt from her community
college degree she says she simply won't
be able to make the payments once they
resume in October now you know I'm a big
uh supporter of small businesses I love
it when people go out and do their own
thing start their own businesses showing
that entrepreneurial spirit that once
made this country great but the message
from this report seems to be that Josie
uh took major Financial risks on the
assumption that the government was just
going to wipe away her debt
unfortunately the magic debt forgiveness
Ferry never arrived and now she's stuck
paying back the money that she decided
to borrow in the first place